in this episode of cloud performance
atlas i helped some garden lovers with
their deployment times are we potting
fake plants stay tuned to find out
rain mages is a company that has a
robust back-end system with lots of
small micro services each one powered by
google cloud functions they ran into an
issue doing 200 or so code deployments a
day their team is wasting a lot of time
waiting for code to be moved around
digging in one of the first things we
noticed was that each GCF for each micro
service had a different set of
dependencies and where they were using
the same dependency chances are they
weren't using the same versions this
threw a massive red flag as versions of
each dependency vary across deployments
dependency cache misses are much more
likely meaning that deployment times
will be longer we were able to unify the
instances to use all of the same
versions of a library meaning they were
more likely to be in the dependency cash
making deployments a little faster
second I noticed a few interesting
statistics with respect to their
deployment setup it looked as though
they were shipping a lot of extra files
around a 600 or so extra config and data
files they would then fetch these files
from the local GCS bucket that their
function stuff was deployed into while
this makes managing micro service
deployments easier it was killing their
deployment time so instead we pushed
their extra data to a separate cloud
storage bucket so that uploads can
happen in parallel and were shared in
some cases resulting in another great
performance boost if you'd like to know
more about our work to fix deployment
times check out the article linked in
the description below and don't forget
to check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts